[Musik]
für ihre gemeinsame glück wenn wir beide
frauen sind und betrieb von
erster kuss ja
nur die pure heft vom traktor gefahren
wurde er im april 2008 ist sondern
schicksal
ich glaube
und was ist mit einer wohnung für sich
so immer für die ganze gesellschaft ein
neuer fall wenn das funktioniert
klimabewegung start am wendepunkt
gab es für die soziale bewegung ist kein
attraktives gibt nur mit straff
die pandemie hätten neue bewegungs
staatsbesitz gesellschaft durchzieht die
rinne ganz andere richtung
muss man sich
also die stücke war schnell ich bin
bewusst ja ganz klar was braucht das in
neuer form klingt the frog gorny das
anliegen
[Musik]
auf rang eins im berner oberland
[Gelächter]
unterwegs ist weg hat auch an der lenk
später wohnen im moment einfach kaffee
ihre gesten sondern flüchtet die
menschen aus der ukraine oder user der
schweiz auf neujahr fahren
also ich sehe stimmen das filmteam der
vorübergehende unterkunft für
geflüchtete ukraine der fünf name machen
reka feriendorf wieder aufgemacht mit
miroslava burg dass die frau wieder zu
erheben
ja ich suche mir
lebt oder arbeitet sie hier es ist eben
groß
[Musik]
du bist der nidda
sollen wir uns gerade dutzend ja ich bin
ja das freut mich sehr
ja das ist unsere arbeit passt dass mein
büro ist mein korrekt
[Musik]
und was machst du eigentlich alles hier
das ist eine aufgabe ich bin sagt
betreuen und mit
dem ihrer schafe ganz unterschiedlich
immer entscheiden kurzfristig entstand
mit ihren lehrerinnen reg rat stellte
otto ludwig stück rief oder organisation
asyl berner oberland bei mir stellt
aktuell ist mira dragonica für die
flüchtete zu machen zusammenarbeit in
teams sehr gut seien sie
in reckendorf sind vor allem frauen und
kinder braucht für ali ist vorübergehend
die station als erster eine form in der
schweiz
hollywood ist eine frau war
rowling cup ist schön brav
ich bin mona betreffe katharina maria
katharina ist mit ihrer tochter victoria
aus dem südosten von der ukraine
geflüchtet ihre statische moment wo
russische besetzt
und die familie ist auch noch
wie halten sie kontakt wenn sie hier
[Musik]
also im moment können sie nicht
kommunizieren weil gibt es keine bienen
also du weißt nicht wo du dein mann ist
weiß nicht wie es seinen verwandten geht
dennis ein schulbrot wo ihre denen dann
im moment
nicht
das ist für mich wahnsinnig schwierig
vorstellbar oder wie man das aushält
oder man sieht hier und man kann nichts
machen und man ließ die schlagzeile und
man sieht die bilder was macht das mit
den menschen ja so dass auch erlebt also
ich persönlich lese jeden morgen
nachrichten also ich denke mir also
jeden morgen stieg auf und lese dass
krieg vorbei ist das willst du dir ja
das wünschen der wahnsinn weil für mich
das was läuft ist wahnsinnig ungerecht
also das ist einfach du bist einmal
aufgewacht und dann hast du gelesen dass
das qi eingegriffen das ist zwar etwas
wie ein albtraum
dass sich die flüchtete da in reckendorf
höhne dusche und ihre erfahrungen teilen
sechs glück für alisa mir speziell auf
ihr kind
mehr zeit mit schuhen wo man kurzfristig
aufbau des pensionierten lehrer ehepaar
aus der lenk macht leipzig dazu mit
lehrpersonen und hilfspersonal
das wirkt sich ihre flucht in recke
zweimal mit ihrer mutter hat sich viel
mühe zu tal mit forderungen
es war sehr schwierig am schwierigsten
war es den mut zu finden weg zu gehen
und du selber also möchtest du hier in
der schweiz
bleiben hier neu anfangen oder möchtest
du fragen zurück
im moment hoffe ich dass ich hier ein
paar jahre bleiben und weiter studieren
kann ich bin sehr froh habe ich einen
platz an der universität gefunden
ob das schon einen platz gefunden
wurde
[Musik]
war auch schon fachhochschule irgendwie
war okay super und was was studierst du
da schütteln unterstand shuttle computer
science computer science informatik ok
lager hofft dass auch ihren frühen die
schweiz konnte ein studienplatz an der
fachhochschule piano show was er jetzt
braucht ist speziell die bewilligung vom
ukrainische staat dass er zum studieren
darf ausreise und nötig ist militär muss
also klar
jetzt war die zukunft aussehen das sie
eigentlich glauben möchte die stadt die
ehrung vor hinter anholt also für die
wenigsten menschen
risse zwischen dem altar der schweiz und
aber ihre alte heimat ukraine sogar
krieg ist und das gerät nur unter
anderem beim atelier kennenlernte mit
der lagerzeit in ihrer wohnung
wohnt in radwege mit andere ukrainische
frauen seien sich alle dauer der schweiz
kennengelernt und teile der drei zimmer
wohnung mit
tiefladern im gegensatz zu der wada ist
für ihre mutter zukunft völlig unklar
leider sehe ich kein ende habe angst
dass ich das noch lange hinziehen und
ich mache mir große sorgen um meine
familie und freunde die in der ukraine
komplett zwischen der ukraine und der
schweiz hin und her klasse ist natalia
kaminski seiner mit ihrer 14 jährigen
tochter alina ist aus der umkämpften
stadt charkiw geflüchtet dass er uns von
der natur trainer mico darum wo
zurückholen
wir sind psychisch am vortag vor ihrer
rückreise die ukraine wie sie ihre
heimatstadt griff mittlerweile nutzt und
wie es labour day tisch weil sie nur
vorbilder von verwandten freunden und
der soziale medien
[Musik]
natalia cummins kader in der schweiz bei
ihrem sohn hat ist das fotobuch vor ihm
mit seiner abschlussklasse
ist der 16 jahren
im herbst wird der vitalia 18 jähriger
militär pflichtig und der ukraine
motorisch
mein sohn möchte ins militär gehen
vielleicht weil sein bester freund
aufgegangen ist
noch einmal mit ihm reden bevor er 18
ist
vielleicht sagt er ich komm
ich hoffe das ist dass alles bald vorbei
wird und will kein zurück nach hause
weil ich möchte sehr nach hause zurück
[Musik]
ich hoffe sehr das ist dann natalia
klingt um ihren sohn der schweiz holen
und ich komme auf jeden fall nochmal
zurück zum nur wie sie ihre gold ja so
eine neue erfahrung das ist nicht jedem
fall ist wo man wirklich aktiv sucht man
doch jetzt wirklich vom einen tag auf
der anderen muss
wir haben zwei stunden schlag um mit dem
anderen mit dem neue und ganz genau so
ist der familienkutsche und ihrem sohn
emil
gangl kind schien vier jahre alt und
stark pflege bitter stieg
als kleinkind wurde der bub von einem
traktor überfahren ein schreckliches
unglück das von einem tag auf den
anderen über die junge familie
hereingebrochen ist
emil wächst auf einem bauernhof auf ein
fröhlicher und aufgeweckte bub sei
gewesen sagen die eltern
mutter latina hat den bergbauern betrieb
von den eltern übernommen und gemeinsam
mit ihrem mann sven bewirtschaftet
es war frühling 2018 als der unfall
geschah auf diesem hof im bündnerischen
pany
da ich eigentlich davon unfalltag von
emil durch einen blitz
hauptkläger passiert also wahrlich sbz
der danach passiert
der großvater von emil arbeitet mit dem
traktor der bub ist für einen kurzen
moment unbeaufsichtigt dann passiert es
der großvater überfährt sein
eineinhalbjähriges groß kind mit der
schweren maschine seit dem unfall ist er
an gebrochenen mann lebt mit der schuld
ein junges leben kaputt gemacht zu haben
der english tanklager und meint
eigentlich sehe also mein erster gedanke
als sie suchen auch weiter
und der nachwuchs ja sagen
was ist passiert
wenisch doppelt sie am
schreien machen und tor und in den luxus
der engel hat auf der stirn zu doug
wright zur spur seit und aus der nase
blutete
in der momentan einfach gewiss kann also
ich glaub mit mega mega schlimm was da
passiert ist das ist nicht irgendwer
dem kopf oder so und und der tony dungy
zum e-mail-abo geschaffen das egal was
jetzt gerade passiert oder
sanitäter und polizei werden alarmiert
der bub kommt auf die notfallstation des
kantonsspitals rudi dennig der notarzt
und den hochgesteckten und denkst du
okay dann aber kämpfte ist findet gerade
urlaub machen
und dann ist das wetter und den oscar
einen monat termin zwischen leben und
tod mutter latina sagt es sei gewesen
als läge ihr kind in einem dunklen
tiefen keller
emil überlebt
mit schweren folgeschäden des unfalls er
ist körperlich und geistig behindert
jetzt dem unfall wird der zu 100 prozent
pflegebedürftig
die beziehung zwischen den eltern sven
und ladiner geht in die brüche
denn hof muss latina verpachten
nicht passiert werden werden wir heute
und intakte familie das muss ich ganz
klar sagen hätten den hof noch und ja
unter funktionieren hätten vorher nehmen
wir aber auch so aber mit den gesunden
kinder
absturz
unzählige operationen mus e mail über
sicher gehen lassen eben ist er zurück
von einer hüft-operation
laufen lernen ist das große ziel
der wahl und muss ich sage einfach cool
und macht sie ein werk das ich
dem ganzen unfalls danke sagt und den
doktor vom e mails wenn mir einfach
allgemein als ich das haus verdanken
dass
sie heute ihren einfach ist
zwei jahre sind vergangen sind deine
bilder vom emil und ich bin jetzt gerade
auf dem weg zum ihnen wieder besucher
seiner familie zum glauben
dass wenn und latin akinci sind zwar
trend bleibt aber im griff arrows und
betreue zahlte ihm
[Musik]
nicht wenn ich jetzt eben in alu
gegangen was bei mittlerweile
vergangenen dekade seit 1 jahr stände
schon schulamt
hat er seine ganzen therapie in vielen
kulturen als eine gespannte dazu muss
ich den super so der bruch kind verbucht
action
irgendwie von vielen ich ja dazu maxi
dass er die operation an der hüfte und
bereitete verpackte auseinander der
hüfte und aber jetzt wirklich bereit zum
laufen das thema aufrecht nach dem
vortrag als großes ganzes stehen ja und
mit dem verfahren aber jetzt so langsam
hofft ja immer der ruf und hoffentlich
dreht sich so greifbar als vor zwei
jahren
entdeckt
[Gelächter]
hallo
vorstellen
[Musik]
mich nimmt wunder wir sehr das unglück
die wenn die im leben für die familie im
alltag noch präsent ist
wir haben ja ab und zu ja es gibt ein
wiedersehen aber
sich den akw wrack wieder dass ich jetzt
gleich vier jahre vergangen und man
vergisst ja und das ist gut das ist
so cool hafner und und einfach für ihn
ist es okay dieses filmjahres
[Applaus]
ältere zeige man werde mit
elektronischer hilfsmittel lernt
kommunizieren
das kindergarten vom e mail ich in
schulen heim zurück
das ist schuhe für kind mit behinderung
dort hatte emil steidle und freunde
kunde
[Musik]
praktisch
und nämlich ganz viel mit
hier ein die ein genauer von k
mit green steht das reicht mir einen
neuanfang habe eure zukunft zu machen
so ein schicksalsschlag oder soll's
ereignis das weiche erstens vor sich so
gar nicht und stellst du dir vor das rad
passieren
ein familienfoto schicksalsschlag
getroffen oder jäger nahm das spiel aus
jux letzten wochen vorstellen was das
ist
nein
da haben wir gar keine zeit zum sonst
wären es verarbeitet also jetzt im
nachhinein hamas verarbeitet wie jeder
anders war es nur noch ich ganz klar
oder aber du bist in
sommerlich zeigen und sagen hat blau
verdienen muss um
so präsent
für mich nur der ebene wichtig auch
erschienen so im vordergrund er kommt
von der kontrolle war konfus schicksal
erzählt und anna lüth dafür dass wir uns
immer an sich getrennt und von mir ganz
klar ich bin drauf
und macht so viel wie möglich dass er
das normale leben genießen kann wie die
an jedes kind auch
dass wir das weiter
also ich finde das einfach
so ein fröhlicher lustiger boxee dass
asien war froh dass er vielleicht bist
du selber
entscheiden das ist aber für das im
moment in china groß 2000 oder aber das
braucht es in sachsen oder also das ist
ganz klar aber dass er vielleicht damals
darf sagt das und das machen oder hat er
einfach das video so cool
dass mit dem cool aber fängt das
passwort zum e mail das hat einfach da
mit dem umbau vom em-sieg lernt jeden
tag zwei wie hund seit ladiner kinky und
sie müsse lernen akzeptieren und arznei
was passierte gibt
[Musik]
wie gott mal mit dem mauerfall browns
schicksal luft zwingt am besten um das
wort die mit dem philosoph und eine
sternstunde moderator so tue sie finde
und vor ihrer familie ich besser du hast
philosoph da fragt man sich ja schon
englisch sowie kann neu anfangen ich so
meine moment kriegen gibt auch
philosophie babys ja es geht der antike
philosophie bitte store ganz wertvolle
hilfestellung an das gefühl wenn man mit
krise umgehört wie man mit katastrophe
umgang mit schicksalsschlag will
eigentlich wissen wir alle dass man
kranken war dass das deutschland
verunfallt dass das manager starb dass
wir durch den staat übernehmen wenn aber
mir verzeichnete die gesamte welt
drücken sie rand und wenn es passiert
wird sich alle aus der bahn und die
historische philosophische versuche ich
eigentlich klasse ruhig geblieben so gut
dass gott und mit denen
schicksalsschläge können
centro wiener fels in der brandung und
und ein rezept ist wenn du sachen
kassandra isla bonita anderer dich als
du immer die stelle liegt zu anderen
aber das tut natürlich wenn s klasse als
klassisches ausschläge sind braucht das
extrem fädelt aberglaube es bleibt einem
gar nicht anders übrig als zu versuchen
ja das ist aber nur eines neuen gips und
und den usa was ist denn der unterschied
zwischen dem eine neue erfahrung war ein
oft wird das schicksal und einwohner
seiner welt also sein dass wir
also eine push factor oder trieb mich
bis weg von ihrer heimat des bei der
ukraine zum beispiel oder vom im alter
das kundenmanagement ein gesunder körper
oder den pc gehen und sie wegrissen
und andere der neuanfang muss aber wer
etwas neues leben auf einen deutschen
das ideal weiter weg
erzielt wenn ich das danke die
vorstellung dass imaginiert sie jetzt
möchte und das hat er bis extrem schön
ist also es gibt von hermann hesse das
jedem anfang wohnt ein zauber zu bringen
das ist wirklich so und die fähigkeit
sich neu zu erfinden
das schreibt das wort philosophin hannah
arendt neutralität nennt also geburt
lichkeit können wir eigentlich zur
mortalität müssen dass staatlich aber
wir sind erst mal geboren und wir können
immer wieder neue geburt die leute das
im metaphorischen sehen kann das projekt
starten wie es ziel verfolgen können wie
sauber neu erfinden ist eigentlich immer
dass ich außerdem treten oder du musst
einfach neujahr in der villa von der
aber ich habe immer die die ich mit mir
im ganzen gepäck wie soll ich mich neu
erfinden
wie wir immer dann am 8 die idee ist zum
beispiel der versuch auch so ein
bisschen situation sozialabbaus wird man
sich erst mal erlaubt oder eine person
sowie musik sie das hat man sie sehr
stolz das ist ein ding der unmöglichkeit
aber man schafft dass mein geschrieben
zum beispiel des frames lang könnt
zurück und wieder retweets und die auto
ort sagte der hai plötzlich mit neuen
augen sind also das fremde sich
aussetzer im fremdem andere scheint es
werden neue blick auf seine tanz
vertrauter und für andere ist er selber
und überhaupt glaube ich ersetze in
fremde und besucher mit andersdenkenden
mit dem anderen aber neu entdecken
fremde spur für sauber und werden das
erst zur usa in den sozialismus die
komfortzone könnte also neuer 52 das
richtige hilfe kein entscheid gegen
anders durch seit man muss keine loosli
und nicht immer ich habe mir dann klar
wer richtig dass es gott liebe ist das
beste beispiel gab es da ja es gibt ein
schönes studie wozu also persönlichkeit
wird sehr frühe schock foren ist also
der genetik der ist erst die erste
pallapies jahren in die pubertät
plötzlich und noch nicht so stabil aber
die größte veränderung findet dann statt
die partner partnerin wechselt als wenn
man neue bezüge
und insofern
stimmt dass also wir sind nicht so
veränderbar aber wenn den grad ihrer
beziehung und das zeigt wie sehr stark
männer beziehungsweise sendern wie sehr
stark auch andere mich zu dem gemacht
was ich im moment bin
dank eines posters dass ich die perfekte
überleitung wie jetzt grund also eine
geschichte von rallye wirklich fast
alles verändert hat
[Musik]
zwei frauen eine große liebe sarah
schatton und jasmin städtchen mitten im
leben haben sie sich gefunden
[Musik]
eine liebe so groß dass sich beide
entscheiden mit langjährig aufgebauten
beziehungen zu brechen und sämtliche
gesellschaftlichen normen zu sprengen
sarah shuttle-flotte bis vor vier jahren
ein komplett anderes leben als bäuerin
ehefrau und mutter
sicher super auf dem hof mit also denke
ich nicht
gegen einfach so so wie sich endlich mit
eigentlich gut aus aus familien wo sich
so gut ich sehe man sich weniger
gedanken
das ist schlecht
die wende kommt als sarah stähli
zufällig jasmin städtle kennenlernt
liebe auf den zweiten blick sei es
gewesen doch dann umso heftiger
[Musik]
batterie entscheidet sich man und hof zu
verlassen
die kinder bleiben auf den betrieb in
engem kontakt mit der nutzer
[Musik]
wir begleiten sarah stähli zu ihren
eltern sie wohnen direkt neben dem
bauernhof ihres ehemaligen mannes
vater hat geburtstag auch zwei ihrer
kinder sind am fest mit dabei die
älteste tochter ist zurzeit im ausland
was die gelernte bäuerin nicht berechnet
hatte die trennung hat massive
finanzielle konsequenzen
das ist in ihrem und
nach weshalb man das ganze rechtlichen
kümmere wo man eigentlich
bin ich
hoffe
dass mir das wird wie oft
ist so in der landwirtschaft der ruf ist
das eigentliche vermögende bauen und
gehört meist der mann
ist es keine vertragliche absicherung
geht die frau leer aus so war es auch
bei sarah haben
die eltern erinnern sich wie verzweifelt
die tochter damals war
[Musik]
52 uhr new hobby von
christof hüls tränen aufgelöst
die hornets gut
und das ist das ist schon
bekommen
das ist froh was er sagt irgendwann
erzählt
aber wirklich gar nichts gutes
das ist hatte verschluckt werden der
glaube aber es ist effektiver sie
sie sehen
können
und natürlich ja nicht mehr
was ich es gar nicht so
drastisch aus nicht zu fassen
mit 42 jahren muss sarah schatten der
großen liebe wegen praktisch bei null
wieder anfangen
also
pro monat von denen zwei hauptfragen sie
panik ist ein muss gestehen dass ich
meine existenz
grundrechte investiv sozialamt gab
ja ich habe mir im normalen
bewerbungsprozesses
auf dem freien markt kann ich mit der
wieder beworben und kaufmännische stelle
stammt
eigentlich war die organe die
versicherungsbranche aber verschiedene
versicherungsbroker vertreten ist kann
zeitlich aber
schlussendlich an die frage dass sie
überhaupt nicht direkt gefunden
[Musik]
mittendrin das leben umkrempeln und neu
anfangen für eine gemeinsame zukunft
neben sarah shahi und jasmin staiblin
kauf dass sich langjährige freunde von
ihnen abwenden und dass ihr leben
künftig außerhalb der gesellschaftlichen
konvention stattfindet
und dort rief sarah stähli einer anderen
art auf dem schöpfwerk aber noch mit
ihrer frau zu
mir bei dir und mir dazu passt dass
nämlich sehr gerne wären wir dazu seht
dann merkt man wie schwierig das thema
fraktionschef dem moment wo du gewinnst
du sara oder im 95
ja
das ist ja eigentlich ein italienischer
medien mit es ist
ja nach dem ersten kuss
ist
also
quasi jeder verträgt muss man sagen also
du bist sexy
also irgendein anders freundinnen kennt
so
aus mit dem hund mit partner den hat
sich hund gewünscht mit einem tessin
bleibt mein restaurant aufgemacht und
daher vorsichtig ort es ist der moment
wo mir der hund konnte h und dennis
sowie kräuter das mit den empfang nach
asien
und schluss ist ganz besonders
meine frau vor
schwieriger gemacht oder einfach
die person
und
[Musik]
kraft sind die beiden frauen übrigens
erst seit kurzem wieder das baumüller
sind sie mit dem wohnmobil unterwegs
also bloß show abgeliefert
im neue dh
also die ep urteil ist speziell wenn es
um neue avantgarde und gehe aber nicht
darum um
wie
ernst ist das mittel zwischen dir
bewusst sei paris ist oder was sarah auf
gibt natürlich also das ist schon immer
das zentralste maxi oder mini am anfang
weiß nicht wie man ist und
sich
nicht
entscheiden
sie
hätten
aber für mich wie sie reagieren
nützlich dort rufen wir ein steak
reagiert
bevor fangen wir ehrlich mit ihnen und
die tochter des mannes bist du alles
okay wenn wir sprechen ja ich bin nicht
sauer aber ich finde dass das super
arbeit
das ist
sie das opfer
mit mit dem jüngste ja immer mit dabei
ist er erfahren wer bis ist ja sehr
willkommen zur oa kaut und der muntere
dreifachsieg für kunst dr das obwohl die
neue erfahrungen oder was der auf den
anderen zur miete oder für da wo er
selber glücklich machen immer mit andrea
träge und am schluss ist also die next
gen hinterhand die konsequenzen dieser
träger wie viel leid dritten mal der auf
den anderen zu verfolgen eigene glück
das ist philosophisch
stunde lang
unmöglich dass sie du bist hier
dass das geld nicht und auf drängen
doch es galt wie nirgendwo die sich
einen neuen werken ruf und ja mit dem
late zu viel glaubt ähnlich ging einfach
nicht zum opfer gemacht jan ist unsere
situation sondern durch und durch
kommunikation und du hast das man nicht
das gefühl hat dass sie
ihren ruhm die sonden mich für euch da
ja ich glaube das ist wirklich
nicht zum opfer zu machen dass
veränderungen im café
also das wäre bis wenn wir darüber reden
was buchs wieder neu erfahren dass man
nicht in erster linie mit dem schlechten
gewissen zeit auch die soli schlimm für
die sonne ist seit mittwoch dass der
situation und trafos ariane geben sie
weiß ich habe es verdient auf jamaika
oder nachsaison verändere ja das auge
des augustinus
sächsische familie struktur wenn man so
besteht aber das hat auch was positives
mitgebracht
für lüthi in einer anderen situation
sind was überlegen ihren erfahrungen
oder durch labore halten ist
schwieriger als ich
spüre was an bord im zwinger was ist für
mit richtiger
schritt als
challenger zloty wirklich wisse ja die
wenigsten und versteht wirklich bewusst
so weiter wo gemini data was die
wirklichen immer wenn es etwas neues
aufbauen denn muss man sich bewusst dass
man immer sich sauberen mitnimmt was
neues ort und wenn es wirklich passiert
für andere denn
dann muss wikipedia war hinter die
meisten leute sind jetzt ein coaching
tätig zu machen
und ja es ist der haupttreiber sven
fischer verlag hofer unbekannt zuge
kommt für kinder grund und hatte wie
kann ich mir das leichter im nachgang
wenn die darum wie geht's weiter und das
ist das ist ein traum weil man so mit
null anfängt wie irak verhängt wie lang
buch zeigen ich bis er wieder
einigermaßen bei hund sehr spannende
frage für
ihr ja diesmal komplett wieder hat
stellt sich finanziell genau also
das ist ganz klar
als die 40 grad dazu
brauchst du diesen philosoph jungs seid
das erlebe ich dass das die größte
veränderung in ihrem leben
das mir die heute auf dem schiff bei den
grünen alles gute
[Musik]
ich bin zurück in recke dorf an der lenk
da wo sie kreativ bruch ukrainische
flüchtlinge
betrifft leider wieder sie ist
überglücklich ihren frühesten bogdan ist
da
begleitet wird die wieder vor dem hera
der ukrainische dolmetscherin
schön euch zu sehen
danke gleichfalls
es ist kaum zu glauben aber hier bin ich
wie schwierig war es für dich in die
schweiz zu kommen
es war ziemlich schwierig ich musste
sämtliche papiere überprüfen lassen
bewilligungen erhalten vom staat und vor
allem vom militär dass ich nicht in den
militärdienst muss und dank des
studienplatzes an der fachhochschule in
die schweiz ausreisen darf ich glaube so
kann ich meinem land am besten dienen
wie war es für dich als er dann
angekommen ist in der schweiz
ich bin sehr sehr glücklich dass alles
geklappt hat und dass er jetzt da ist
denkst du du machst dir so eine art
neustart in der schweiz
ja das leben hat eine wende genommen
hier bin ich und mache pläne für meine
zukunft in der schweiz ich möchte einen
abschluss machen und nicht
spezialisieren ich werde mein bestes tun
um diese chance zu packen
das recker dorf hätte ich schon ziemlich
klärt nur knapp 100 menschen im oktober
menschen gefunden hat denn kurz fähre
dorf leader der tour ist
nur der planer ist und auch ihre wg
mitbewohnerin natalia kaminski mit der
tochter alina sie wofür es bei woche
ihren sohn hat wählen die zone
du bist in die ukraine gegangen ist
daher jetzt
es ist nicht gekommen er wollte nicht
kommen er wollte nicht kommen
er hat mir gesagt er wolle auf jeden
fall in der ukraine bleiben er werde
nicht mit mir in die schweiz kommen wie
war das für dich
es war sehr schwierig
es ist sein leben seine wahl für mich
war es physisch und psychisch eine sehr
anstrengende reise
der sohn wurde natalia kaminski hat sich
gegen inter und für der ukrainische
militärdienst entschieden wird natalia
die momentum klar wie es für sie und
ihre 14-jährige tochter alina vita gott
glaubst du für die menschen hier wird
zum beispiel der natalia die ja so ein
bisschen hin- und hergerissen ist kann
man überhaupt neu anfangen in einer
solchen situation wenn man hört
auf mit der zukunft planen dann dann ist
das ja das dann hat es keinen sinn also
und ich bin auch die meinung dass man
uns versuchen also ich muss sagen ich
bin schon optimistisch aber es ist schon
sehr schwierig in dieser situation etwas
zu planen man muss versuchen also wieder
musste die arbeiten wir haben die
aufgabe also wie menschen leben einfach
weiter
um ihr seid was ihre sehr helfen
schwierige situation sehr hilfsbereit
schafft vor der bevölkerung und sieht
auch in der schweiz enorm spüren
der ukraine ist pandemie eine andere
große vor tricks bei mir ist alles damit
beschäftigen und sind in der schweiz
ist im land das
im neuen gesellschaftlichen deine
vereine ist eine maßnahme gegner der
roland schey quasi über nacht zum
freiheits creek corniche direct connect
100 hoffnung ist während der pandemie
mit ihm und wechseln
diese freiheit das wort dieser finger
und rom fahren vom nebel aktion ist
toggenburg zur rolle und bh dieses
gehöre zum härten vor der freiheits
trifft keine schuld sagt v2
freiheit nicht sagt nun aber sogar zwei
mediale präsenz
und zentrum würde so eine große
strahlkraft der blick hinter die
kulissen jetzt ist zwischen nach dialog
und er ist hanni vorwerk
der begann zu wenig aus freiheitlicher
sie schlagen uns sexy ob er als reporter
vom messer auf ihren der kreis vor der
freiheit für ihren roman jedes
klassische medien wie etwa so groß wie
ein virus
rolex aus dem block entspannt gemeinsam
mittag und
sympathie
legt man eine sache umgesetzt dann
brächte geworden die messen was ich dass
der präsident der alltag firma
jetzt sind
willkommen
wer sie sind sagt jahres brachte 42
fachfrau logistik
55 diplomierte landwirt oder sogar schon
für
den vfl maliger beziehe im alter
zwischen 16 und ski
sitzen zum hertragen vor der
freiheitliche nabg im finanzplan
und orchestriert dem
geschäft zum dreifacher oder zu
freiheits
trichet hatte die märkte im april lag
und garten das mittagessen und kaffee da
muss ich wirklich sagen ich will euch
die
amerikaner so weit möglich emotional
aber ich bin auch die bühne gegangen bei
der gleiche buch kanak
stehen zum parieren war
4850 freiheit nichts mit grad bis zum 22
vom rolle dazu bei die krone
der pandemie redstone vor dem plan denn
ich habe was ich jetzt sage wenn dort
mit krempe land dahin wird also wenn ich
stelle auf dem sorgt die hängematte
liegen und nicht gestorben ich finde
den wegen der wenig regen zur gab es nie
da die aktion um die klein wenig minimal
nicht dazu ich beginne
gibt es denn gut basierte federle ja ich
finde es sehr gut dass du dich ebenfalls
den hyde und das meine ich positiv
wichtigste positive gelang es sich genau
wie wir morgen
muss ich raus vorgehen
wollte davon jedoch vor den folgen von
wilders
ja aber auch die
derzeitige freiheit
die modularen stärken
[Musik]
private
qualität
können sie noch gewichtiger
bedarf mit
damaligen mitteln hand im infobus ja
noch ganz
die gibt es nicht da sind
er hat noch so oft wie sonst drohen 80
davon
sowie seine hohe medium
soll ich sagen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die der hier dies
sei gefordert die strafe
[Musik]
stellt
[Applaus]
das chrome gestanden für die 3 so wie
mir hört
gelddruckmaschine freiheitsstrafe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist mitte november zwei wochen stimmt
schweiz zum zweiten mal das gesetz auch
für die
demonstranten kobe japan erschlossen
organisatorin freiheitlich rat in der
summe die bei jeder maßnahme kritisch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
aber ja mit höherer leistung spät merkte
sie dass sie geraten haben gebäude vor
dem aus steht also sie meinen also
effektiv ist selbst vom uno
hochkommissariat für mannschaft
die 24 sturm mit der freiheits trichter
sie abgelaufen er fühle mich von der
garbe rollt auf dem zocalo
platz im in auge sieht freiheitskriege
die truppe mit 1 gemeinsame nenner dank
dieser elite die pandemie inszeniert und
dies nach strenger vater manipuliert und
mit licht sind der digitale empfang
bringen sie ihre antwort verständnis und
zur
königssee nach der begegnung einige
andere aber musikalisch korrektur
übergeht es bleibt richtig
[Musik]
mit laufender kamera
eine
strikte erst genau dass die verwüstetes
tochter
die tour zwar noch nötig haben
mollet sind - sony hat
ja dann im
letzten jahr
auf
diesen abschlüssen habe schließlich
zwang alexa und
mit der trichter und zornig sind damit
für mich selber abschließen ist dann hat
dennoch ist zugleich
neue auto
während der pandemie hat sich
freiheitskriege untereinander
zerstritten sozial ist zu sparen der
vorwurf an roland schey
knackiger kälte und unter anderem
medienauftritt gemacht die namen von der
freiheitsdressur nicht abgesprochen
[Musik]
und zwei jahre richtig
mit scada das ist so und ich bin ich
kenne mich lieber moment erstaunlich
widerrufen love it und könnt ist eins
sicher nicht
ausgeheilt auschwitz theorie oberland
quark warnung vor einem jahr
freiheitsstrafe nicht unter dem namen
für die heiz trikots untersagt dass
solche sondern
meldete ham and william mittlerweile
notieren und müssen die staatlichen also
meinst
du ich werde aber zeit des vulkans seit
neujahr form dies ist ein neuer fall
aber mit der freiheit
aber nicht
nur
was sie feststellen der roland keth die
und das umfeld sind der festen
überzeugung der staat könnte im
krisenfall us bürgerinnen und bürger und
nur gut versorgt
[Musik]
das ist für mich ich denke
wir wissen der schweizer
soll jedermann
strom aber das ist ja im moment es war
schließlich stehe jetzt der bundesrat
hatte bereits informiert prognosen strom
einfach unser usain
konflikt barista das notstromaggregat
hattrick geschafft hat die doktoren mit
war
aber
schwierig da es keine dass ich
nichts von dem ist nicht so dass ich
irgendwo ist ein großer chor liegt da
wie die linke schafft laut ok als
berechtigt oft ja ich
denke dass ich jetzt da ich wohne mit
trap tränen laufen also meinte barca
spielen treppe monate muss ich ehrlich
sagen weniger anbieten wenigstens folge
sorgen das ist ja auch hinter direkt vor
dem laden den heißt alles durchgerechnet
und knoop gibt es doch recht ungleiche
paar
mal auf platz zehn
unternehmen die das gefühl ich mal für
dich stimmt
nicht im eigenen garten sondern
außerhalb des nahrungsmittel aber zum
beispiel auf mallorca wo es gerade am
ernte
[Musik]
und sie blüht welt parat sie aber parat
für was und wie videos gott verstehen
und somit eine vorbereitung ist oder
nicht lässt die frau bosch müssen sich
dann auch eine wäre oder anders musste
war
also bist du bewaffnet ich bin bewarf
sie auch ganz klar
mit und regelmäßig trainieren
kurzwaffen was kann ich die schwierige
daran schnitt die prager trainiere aber
holt zwar verspricht fußball war von
einem millimeter
kaliber einfach also wenn man
irgendetwas erlebten während der
pandemie denn ist eine unglaubliche
training und gesellschaft oder und in
rom wo extrem aggression zugeknallt und
wenn du mir letztens regeln ja denken
stets will ich mich unbedingt das beste
zeichen
von der schmiede natürlich ein stück hat
das ist auch legitim aber dichte familie
haltige legitim vertrag den ich sage ich
glaube ich bin nicht aggressiv unser
wachstums hat mir jetzt aber mit werbung
und der freiheits trifft man dann in der
kundgabe mit deeskalierenden erwachsener
ja mehrmals
mit richard und bemühte gelbe westen
wachsen sie zum
manchmal bist du hier habe es ja
irgendwie kurios amüsant fernsehgeräts
das mal aber so bald zum waffe gott da
wir jetzt mehrere schränke sowie also
wenn wir irgendwas weiß auf derweil denn
je mehr für das ist umso mehr passieren
wer oder was wäre bedroht ich bin
eigentlich sicher jetzt betrug mich ja
nicht immer drei tätern ist sophia
unterstützen das ist sicher die spitze
tradition insofern schützenvereine dass
du das du deinem hobby schnarcher gottes
steht zu mir das ist schön und da finde
das wirklich aus im fall das ist sicher
durch das kabinett doch schon im
schlimmsten fall machte sie dann
schlussendlich so oder so
landesverteidigung zu salzgitter die
jungen
an shetty ich zu meiner frage klare
antwort wobei man sich bedroht fühlt
krimi bis zum schluss nicht über
offenbar der sich als krisenszenarios
recht leid wo sie handeln rechtfertigen
und zum ziel hat für sich selber sorgen
und unabhängig sie vom staat
bossert philosoph moderator von der
sternstunde philosophie
das interessiert mich oder es gibt
menschen die träume nicht nur für
persönliche neujahr fangen sondern eben
von gesellschaftlichen oder
freiheitspreis beispiel was ist der
größte unterschied
der größte unterschied ist dass man
nicht ein eigenes soziales
einfach dass
alle anderen mitziehen oder große teile
kritische masse davon wenn man findet
bis lauf grundsätzlich falsch unserer
gesellschaft und letztlich ist natürlich
der anspruch dass sie gesellschaftlich
muss verein unter die kürzungen
persönlich erleben dazu gewählt vieles
von ihm natürlich gesellschaft bestimmt
der gesetze der vorschrift für kultur
und so weiter was ist denn der wunder
und ursprung pflicht auf dem kühlen ich
will gesellschaft verändert viele neu
erfahren dass man die tv-rechte graf
also damals
ungerechtigkeitsempfinden das richtig
oder auf die idee das ist einfach nicht
nachhaltig ist aus dem so nicht
weitermachen aber die ganze klima
bewegung findet peter diese projektes
und geschadet da zukünftige generationen
kann man für user was das buch damit
einen anstoß wirklich einen neuanfang
nimmt der heutige zieht wird die große
problem oft menschheit wartet die sind
ja globaler natur und einmal den
klimawandel migration
digitalisierung philipp vor dem problem
haben wir nur als gesamt die menschheit
lösen und das machst du dich schwierig
wir mussten ihn oral die schweizerinnen
und schweizer über zügiges und reich die
ganze welt und wir muss eine art finden
miteinander für globale gerechtigkeit
sorgen und institutionen schaffen wo es
zu einigen die türe setzen und sich
bindet und bevor ich natürlich dass wir
den druck liegt und zeit solle die
anderen zehn mal vor ich bin sicher
nicht der dom oder vor ort und alle
anderen haben also ihr profitieren auch
vom alter system also klappt das sind
die große herausforderung für die
heutige zeit dass man als menschheit ein
weg finden
nachhaltig schlappe und muss sich zander
obwohl das so schwierig ist werden wir
vielleicht der leidensdruck gar nicht so
stark gespielt danke firma lief postert
stichwort klima jugend das ist schon
gefallen und der klima jugend der
genauso angefangen dass junge menschen
heimat gefunden hat mit genau dem
anspruch der sich seit wir brauchen in
gesellschaftlichen neu erfahren
zehntausende vor allem junge menschen
gehen fürs klima auf die straße
eine die massen mobilisiert jonas campus
17 jähriger schüler eine
[Musik]
solche jugendbewegung hatte seit den
1980 er jahren nicht mehr gegeben
eine bewegung die den planeten vor dem
kollaps retten
[Musik]
und auf 94 weiter da kommt es wohl wenig
sinn zu behaupten mit unserem
konsumverhalten können wir die
klimakrise behindern der blutjunge jonas
campus geht seinem bett der
klimabewegung
[Musik]
die eltern sorgen sich um ihren sohn
tätige und onlinemedien
image von gernot und rückflüge dass
seine trittfest unser trader und durch
meine richtige name bekannt und ja die
zeit schon die ein oder andere negative
kommentare oder
finde das muss man sagen dass das nicht
die aufmerksamkeit
was wollen die jungen erreichen sind das
realistische ziele die jungen aktivisten
stellen sich bei radioeins den
kritischen fragen von roger schawinski
der name dieses gesuch direkt nach der
rede wo am samstagabend mir sind die
organisatoren im studio man fordere
gestellt worauf die kalte überweist
diese meldung gesetzt werden die zahl
von familien die so denken sie wenn die
tat instanz sondern mir dass alle ideen
mit dem letzten bericht vom weltklimarat
auseinandergesetzt und die zeit mit
emissionen muss b 20 zentimetern arbeit
des vereins künftig ganz auf die ganze
wahl global und kritisches
industrieland sei in vielen habe es mir
ganz klar ist die wissenschaftlich
vorgegangen und
mitgestalter dialog mit klima wie gross
schätzen johnson die dass das passieren
wird
die große chance sieht es mir überlassen
und
somit realitätsfremde gedanke dass
kluges oder reparieren müssen
realistischen szenarien aufzeigen
anlass für das privileg das man da es
gar nicht realisieren
indem sie mit imperialistischer den
verdacht haben wir politiker ihre
pfarrer hermann kant oder ohne korsett
und
faktisch mit hand der krise und nehmen
jetzt bis mache
jonas campus und seine gruppe von
klimaaktivisten auf dem weg nach davos
die chemisch schüler aus wetzikon wollen
am weltwirtschaftsforum für den
klimaschutz demonstrieren
jonas muss noch eine rede vorbereitet
klimakrise
ohne brutal stimmung in der herti
wir sind momentan gut drauf ich bin
gestellt acht jahre lang rektor dazu
geschrieben
inspiriert wird die klima jugend von der
16-jährigen greta thunberg die ikone der
klimabewegung ist auch am welt mit ihren
auftritten zwingt sie politik und
wirtschaft sich mit dem thema klima zu
beschäftigen
[Musik]
was wollen sie den mächtigen hier
mitteilung hier
dass sie versagt haben und dass wir
keine zukunft haben wenn wir die
klimakrise jetzt uns packen
warum sind sie so bestimmt
heute würde ich es nicht machen würde
ich mich schlecht flirt ich will zurück
schauen können und sagen ich habe alles
versucht
im alter von 17 jahren stellt jonas
campus mit gleichgesinnten eine bewegung
auf die beine die die schweizer jugend
belegt
mit der stärkung ein reserviertes machen
um ihr werdet wieder ihn in
solchen fertige will die mindestwerte zu
starker zukunft ist damit grundlage mehr
und mehr so lange machen bis wir das
erreichen
[Musik]
die aufnahme vor der klima jugend dass
ich früh york sie 2009 zu jetzt sitzt
der junge mode keine gelernten der zur
ikone verstehen als krampus auch ist
quasi next generation
aktiv fürs klima 15 zähler frei die
schülerin aus dem 2 die durch engagierte
über das reden gerade noch teuer und
dunham der roland keth einmal vorschlug
eine
ehemalige freiheitspreis der bringe man
also soziale protestbewegung thema wobei
die idee letztlich ganz viele
schlagzeilen gesorgt und wenn du sie
finden ein eigenes motiv ergänzen oder
gibt es gemeinsamkeiten
jonas anfang
wir sind von alt sieht höchstens
mit der klima nach abgang aber ständig
andere punkt meine hand zwei jahre
pandemie hintere ist mir halt in ukraine
für torwart aber da hätte ein spannendes
knie gebrochen
um orientieren und ich gab es für die
soziale bewegung gibt keine alternative
es gibt nun mit strass straßen mit
manchen zusammen oder im dok-film aus so
gut und ich meine dinge die euch vor ich
sage ich habe nun der kampf für das
ganze leben lang ja das ist das ist das
wo man irgendwie dass das das plant die
manchmal ich spüre die unterhose
gemeinschaft wäre straße sind und das
ist nicht mehr möglich und das ist das
schwierig das wie das so alles bringen
aber auch nicht versucht hat und es
klingt als einmal wieder aber natürlich
oder äußerst zynisch 1,5 grad grenze
erreichen global und das tut sie mir
momentan nicht aber das ist nicht schuld
dass ich
untätigkeit von politik und wirtschaft
war ich wie drinnen der fossilien und
100 handelt und klimaschutz konsequenten
klimaschutz betrieben ja meine zeit
klima jugend die bewegte ist also taxi
aber eigentlich sind setzt ja herzlichen
prof was sagst du also steffen ich sage
dass das nicht stimmt also immer noch
ganz viele junge menschen ganz
verschieden die menschen aktiv sind und
immer wieder neue menschen die sich
engagiert und ich finde gerade mir mein
letztes nationalstaffel kristalle doch
verluste ganze schützen das haben wir
auch jederzeit direkt im schnitt
irgendwie an bord klar wenn man die
belecker die damit den macher wie wir
reagieren dass der mond stationen zum
beispiel nämlich das einzige mittel sind
uploads öffentlich nicht kurz stichwort
weniger weile zum damaligen nötige gehör
verschaffen der rundschau am anfang vor
dem sommer einbricht braucht wo sie
thematisiert das zum teil zu sehr
radikale schrecklich illegale mittel
greifen wird dagegen schnell miteinander
[Musik]
rum lang ein klima aktivisten es dank
markus setz
hey
ich und mache die hand geredet mit
politikerinnen mittels der wirtschaft
mehr einwohner stadt demonstriert auf
ganz legale aktiviert die art und dies
aber was sollen wir machen die hand
gemacht werden kein geld wir könnten es
nun mit eurer körper mit dem was meine
hand gesetze
bilder von ra autobahnausfahrt in der
westschweiz wo sich aktivisten am boden
bleibt
siegfried lenz im aargau wo der
zementkonzern holcim steigen wird
vergrößere sich
massiv aufträgt hängt über aktionen vor
der klima jugend und zum teil auf
aktionen wo es stimmt ich eigentlich
alles erlaubt wenn der zweck ein garten
ist es gab es frage ist ja immer etwas
wird man sich fragen wie wäre das ist
fundamental
zerstörung unserer
lebensgrundlage wirklich über die
klimakrise verursacht ganz bewusst
verursacht werden danke der
rohstoffkonzern und die sind natürlich
mittel mit dem stationen aber auch wie
konkret die effektive blockade wie zum
beispiel das tanklager in rümlang
durchaus erlaubt sogar notwendigen
man hat das verpflicht
mittelstands leicht und dann muss man
eigentlich sonst so auch zu und klettert
wie spiele oder wotan der seit jahren
hin dass mit politik getroffen mit als
mit einer trophäe und und dass man auch
eine so oft gehört betroffen ist das ist
ja ich auch irgendwie aus aus aus junge
person nur noch ein gewisses vertrauen
versuchspersonen und symmetrisch das ein
klarer bruch sie und hat ihn ja dazu 42
kinder fragen ja okay dass sie stehen
schafft einfach nicht mit wissenschaft
klar gargano ist es das interesse trat
aus der klimakrise zu
vertrauen
verloren
das großes zutrauen manche die manche
die weile da jetzt widerruf standard das
glaube ich aber nicht eure gier weil das
ist sicher bis jetzt klappt red
verbindet durch das fordert eigentlich
aber genauigkeit ist regierung
existiert nicht mehr um die sache wo du
jetzt gehört mir als campus bekannt wo
können wir sie ganz sicher aber auf der
anderen sieht ich bin euch junge hatte
einen ganzen garten also mit ihm blüht
jetzt vorstellten hat zwar niemand in
das lokal was mir da sowas mini
generation um generation verwiesen
eltern habe ich eigentlich hinter lernt
und verluste jetzt mir einfach wacher
und hier umfrage social media goes to go
flüge und dann 1 51 prozent an der media
abstimmen ob das ist ein ich bedanke
mich oder meine träume wieder einmal
flügen jetzt geholfen ohne ja nicht
fehlen die frage warum und wieso
das ist jetzt noch interessant also da
frage ich mich warum heißt denn du
irgendwie kroner maßnahme protestiert
und ist eigentlich mit dem klima jugend
trainer und ich noch geschlafen oder
jonas zuspruch zur ausgabe nicht
dogmatisch
17 jugend wachsen die ich besitze
sie darauf dass letzterer sondern also
ich bin ein relativ schwach und trete an
ihr tank dass ich überhaupt mal eine
kultur- und man sie haben mir sehr viel
für 50 gewertet so einmal brauchen
doppelt sicher so genaue
regierungskritisch und wachs das ganze
system stimmt gegen sohn jeden sky und
aber sie kann also sagen es ist
schwierig also müssen angenommen ein
handlicher brot und probieren probieren
aber der motor waren was motiviert
das momentane 22 soziale protestbewegung
allerdings politisch recht auf der
landkarte an einen anderen ort aber
gleich im gleichen boot wurde der
norweger ich glaube eher weniger
klar wenn der fundamental andere
vorstellung also gerade klima strecken
die erzählt mit solidarität schafft
damit die menschen mehr wo weniger
privilegiert sind so schüchterne emil
wies sind und mehr zuschauer für die
klimakrise betroffen sind und ich glaube
ja gerade wie der grieche länger ist es
ja schon wenige das farbige irgendwie
solidarität mitglieder diese gruppen und
zerlegte
ja und ich glaube also herr schlagseite
seht ihr nicht so recht was dir gott und
ich glaube hier ein schumi vollständige
also die klima stellt katja der klima
aktionsplan um mir ganz viel maßnahme
auf china das braucht dass wir die
klimakrise noch das
schlimmste noch verhindern
und genau da auch strategisch machen wir
uns gedanken über
die
klare vorstellung vom automatischen
systeme werden heuer von missouri so
stimmt dass ich das jetzt einfach ein
gps und sie sind für yb also ich hoffe
es auch nichts gefühle berühren mir zu
hause ist in
unseren augen ist ja also da muss jetzt
tatsächlich
wie von hits glück hat das ist familie
ferrari sondern darum in europa 30 liter
verbraucht und die genitale luftstroms
minderheits langweilig ist die genauso
bezüglich verliebt ist
jetzt wie im preisbereich der familien
bezahlbare
branche vor
linke hand und wenn du dann bezüglich
aufs gas das durchaus verhindert dass
andere gemeindlichen hervor
dann ist das also ist das von mädels
legitim und sei vom jesuskind mit
egoismus zu
einer studie zeigen dass weltweit mehr
als 20 millionen manche dort in viele
gestorben sind und ich finde dass ich
das ist etwas wo man muss das
unterscheidet uns ja eben auch dort 27
millionen geräte das ist gut und recht
aber immer verlässlich zum jahr 2024 der
zusammenhalt und den ort wie versender
der altonaer weltkrieg unternehmen
gestohlen oder das land nicht dann in
zwei bis drei oder vier oder einer
wohnung soll so mehr ist er nie fertig
da am tisch zeigte sich der clash
zwischen extrempositionen aber auch
zwischen einiger und fakten diese
forderung für uns als gesellschaft
grundstück die lösung für zukunft finden
und hier überhaupt mitternacht durch
vorher gesagt hat du glaubst eigentlich
ab menschen da gab es wenige regierung
nicht unbedingt am start du glaubst
menschen die so etwas wie die ehrung ist
wenn man so einen neuanfang machen oder
will ich bei frau ein richtungswechsel
aber wer glaubt stunden als musiker
jonas also ich bin überhaupt weniger
stark gestartet aber in der ganzen
anlage richtig
super dass man sich bei der großkonzerne
beim geld muss so weiter und ich
bin zwar positiv dank der man schon
grundsätzlich
sehen wir sehen wir relativ
egal ob die folgen lang
war das paar zu den fixpunkten zittern
ganz normal arbeiten als minijobber
zügig und ohne nach gott nur abwärts ich
meine klar editionen pessimismus
verfallen und das storno gerade verliebt
war irgendwie sich mit der klimakrise
beschäftige das gesamtjahr es wird mit
gemacht was dem gekracht wird momentan
ist schicken mir ihre schöne 1,2 grad
erhitzt der wald und so schon viele
tolle tradition india mit hitzewellen
und so weiter aber
gleichzeitig finde ich glaube
pessimismus falsch ich glaube wenn wir
nicht einfach alle findet aber alle sich
so schlecht und es wird nicht mehr dann
haben wir sogar ab vergaß aber ich
glaube so weit ich danke ich heute hier
weil ich sehe dass man andere waldrand
erschaffen dass es möglich ist dass mir
klar jetzt schade für die klimakrise die
haben was sich jetzt sport aber doch
noch ganz viel schaffen und retter und
darum bin ich eigentlich recht
optimistisch dass nicht ein wandel
landschaftlich schöne dozent dorf
sensibilisiert mobilisiert und motiviert
ich glaube da man
kann also ich hoffe es für
richtig dass zum teil wirklich nötig und
mit blick auf die ressource ist
dank dem aus in der box die jonas campus
fehlerfrei und roland frank die
einigkeit aber die ist noch gar nicht
beantworten oder der neue erfahrung also
blieben als gesellschaftlicher
und wenn ja wir schaffen oder neuanfang
gesucht so nicht stattfinden und andere
thema im hafen vor der serie und wo
nicht persönlich sehr interessant viele
persönliche neuer erfahren dass schon
mal erlebt dass ihr das gemacht und was
was hängt oder wie erfahren was sehr
viel ist cool für den
moment oder was jetzt für uns
schwieriger gemacht kommentar der frage
hängt an der uni oder allianz
begeisterung zu ende der sendung aber so
ergänzt die kommentare und ist gesperrt
danke für das interesse unter druck auf
youtube abonnieren daneben laufen